heidi klum and winnie harlow give it up
um in honor of their show making the cut
it is time for a little pop quiz called
making the cut but with what
oh it's awesome i'm just going to do
this the whole time when he's been kind
enough to host as heidi and i battle it
out with our covet safe distance full
super cool hands um so winnie will you
explain the game well i
look fabulous doing this of course so in
this game
i'll ask a serie a series of questions
all right the answer to each question is
something that
cuts anything from chef's knives to
edward scissorhands
oh the first person to hit the buzzer
and give the right answer
gets the point okay ready but steals
are allowed if kelly wins the right side
of the audience gets a cool prize
and if heidi wins is still upside and
her photo goes up in the blake shelter
on the wall
of champions would you beat kelly clark
i hate that one
stupid wall all right guys here we go
first
question what cutting device
was famously part of a massacre in texas
chainsaw oh
my god i went like i didn't go to movies
i went like real quick
right here's the next one what cutting
device might you see going back and
forth in someone's
front of house landmark what
a what a what a lawnmower
a long one i was like what did you did
you say a land mower i'm so happy i'm
not playing this game
oh my god we're gonna get your picture
already too
just for landmark where you're going
kelly you gotta catch up
what was the cutting machine called that
you would chop what that would chop off
your head that's so
scary oh wait oh oh
has she
do you notice that i'm hitting the
button and my glove it doesn't light up
does anyone else notice that
is this rigged i'm going straight to the
live show
oh my the competition is hot right here
right now
thank you all right next question what
is the name of the long
curved blade that death is seen carrying
a seat the cyclist
[Applause]
i don't even know how to pronounce it
that's not in my vocabulary yeah
okay heidi three kelly i know i know
where's the next one for all of you game
of thrones fans oh okay
i didn't watch it yeah dancers
they're they're not alive they're
they're they're the white people yeah
the the the the the th
oh my god i know who they are the white
walkers
come on we all got this one okay what is
it oh don't shame it
already no we no okay
when you're getting a manicure what
cutting tool
are they likely to use nail clippers
scissors yup oh man
oh man hey chris hey chris you don't
need to hold up that we know that i'm
moving
okay you don't need to hold up your
fingers four to two
that's just right here
is the next one ah which
superhero played by ryan reynolds walks
around with a pair of katana swords
deadpool
it's one of my favorite superheroes oh
my god it's amazing even deadpool 2.
sequels usually suck no not that one
incredible yeah yeah way to go ryan
right so here we go four three here's
the next one
okay this precious gem is so hard
that it can diamonds
it's my birthstone that's what i'm
talking about
it's time right there
i have any more questions this is a
tiebreaker one more one more
one more oh my gosh oh my gosh
okay okay what cutting tool is also
the name of a type of puzzle
a jig no i don't know jigsaw
all right guys with five points heidi
is the winner
[Music]
i'm tired damn it oh thanks for playing
hardy congratulations
um what happened so you get to go on the
wall
yeah it's so exciting um that also means
that all the people on the left side
um y'all won so and this is my show and
i don't want you to go home a loser so
everyone makes the cut today so let's
give everyone the prize
the nama cold press juicer is one of the
strongest juicers on the market
with up to 60 more juice the number is
engineered to provide more nutrients and
better flavor
it has multiple functions so you can
make almond milk
oat milk and even sorbets plus it's kids
safe and super easy to clean which all
your mamas are gonna love that
you're all getting a chance to start
juicing because everyone in our house
seats is getting a number juicer
yes not honey
because she beat me jig i just said jig
why did i say just
jig i don't know why i did that i don't
know i've been
well you did better than me but it
wouldn't work the first few times okay
and since heidi won
following the show her photo will be
mounted on
the blake shelton wall of champions who
beat kelly clarkson
um it's so great i'm excited for you um
a big hand for heidi klum and winnie
harlow everybody
that was awesome and i love your thank
you making the cup premieres on amazon
prime video on july 16th you all gotta
check it out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever